الان هذا الخطاب موجه في الاساس واذا لما
اتى بنفسه موجه بالاساس للشعب الامريكي
الذي يضغط على ناخبيه الجدد الذين انتخبهم
ودفع بهم الى المجلسين خاصه مجلس النواب
الان في روسيا هذا اخر عمل لها كرئيس
لمجلس النواب هناك رئيس جديد سيكون هو من
الجمهوريين حتى قالوا الزعيم الاقليه في
الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي عندما
سئل عن قضيه المساعدات التي تقدم
الاوكرانيا قال معظم الجمهوريين يؤيدون
ذلك هذه معظم عليها خلاف لان العكس تماما
هناك من يرى ان الحزب الجمهوري طاقه عني
بهذه المليارات التي تصرف على اوكرانيا في
الوقت الذي كان فيه الحدود الجنوبيه
للبلاد باوضاع غير مقبوله انسانيه
للمهاجرين
سكان المنطقه الحدوديه بين تكساس مثلا
والمكسيك
قضيه ايضا السلاح الذي تحدث عنه الرئيس
فايدن هذه المنظومه كان يرفض اعطائها
لاوكرانيا لانها كانت قد تفسر من جانب
رئيس بوتين بانها استفزاز الان يؤكد هذه
منظومه الدفاعيه الى اي مدرسه هذا الكلام
الرئيس الروسي على الاقل تصريح الانسان
وزير الدفاع عندما قال ان روسيا مفتتح على
اي جهود او دعوات للسلام هذه الدعوه تحدث
عنها اليومسكي امام الكونجرس بمجلسي وقال
هنا خطه سلام
مناقشها مع بيضه لكنه لم يفسح عن هذه
التفاصيل هل هذه الخطه قابله للوصول الى
حلول الوسط اعتقد ان الجو العام لا يميل
الى هذا الامر والعكس تماما هو بالفعل من
ناحيه العمليه استمرار لهذا النزاع المسلح
الى على الاقل لابد الموضوع